Speaker 2: If you want to see some real cringe on
this entire Martha's Vineyard and just generally
flying immigrants, bussing immigrants around,
stunned. I have video for you today of Fox News
sending listen, I don't know who speaks Spanish
at Fox News like I don't know who they have that
speaks Spanish. But one guy that multiple times
have been has been sent to speak Spanish to
migrants is a reporter named Griff Jenkins. That's
not the guy on the screen right now. This is Steve
Doocy, who's going to cut to Griff Jenkins.
It's hard to think of a more cringe video.
Throughout the last couple of weeks of this
immigrant, Martha's Vineyard, Washington,
D.C., buzzing airplane fiasco. Then this video.
Venezuelan migrants, mostly Venezuelan
migrants. Not all were, quote, interviewed
by Griff Jenkins. And he can barely speak
Spanish. He has no idea what they're saying.
The migrants can barely understand his Spanish. It
almost seems like a parody. Take a look at this.
Speaker 1: From our southern border have just
arrived outside Vice President Kamala Harris's
residence at the Naval Observatory in.
Speaker 2: Washington, D.C.. By the way,
this is also part of the stunt, right? Send a bus
of migrants right to where Kamala Harris lives is.
This doesn't help anyone. This is just a stun.
Speaker 1: Griff Jenkins is live on the scene to
tell us more. Griff, is that Massachusetts
Avenue that I'm looking at right there?
Yeah. Good morning, Steve. And Brian, this bus
just arrived moments ago. I talked to some of the
folks. Apparently, this bus has come from Del
Rio, Texas, and it sort of jumped on the bus,
told me and is for me dead on the earth.
Speaker 2: So that way, if you if you missed
what that was, that was did Don Davis did
Don Davis. And even if you speak Spanish,
it's like, what is he saying? What he's
trying to ask is dead on. That is, where
are you from? That's the question. The
Don Davis sounds more like a Kanye album.
Speaker 3: Than this one.
Speaker 1: Venezuela, I think less.
Speaker 3: No.
Speaker 2: Okay. So he asks. She says she's from
Venezuela, asks if she speaks English. She says.
Speaker 1: No, Tina, no. La la la. President
Harris these okay. Frontera. Serrano.
Speaker 2: Okay. So when he says there Frontera
Cerrado, what he means is the borders closed.
Kamala Harris said the the border is closed now.
I don't know whether it's reasonable to
think that Venezuelan migrants who have
been on a bus for a whole bunch of time and
coming through Mexico and all these things
that they would necessarily be up on the latest
declarations from Kamala Harris. So the entire
thing is bad faith. But here's the answer.
Speaker 1: La Frontera is cerrado or I'll be
airto. Oh yeah, I'll be there too.
Speaker 2: So he asks, Is the border open
or closed? And she says, It's open. And this
is supposed to be some kind of gotcha moment.
Speaker 1: What's she saying, Steve? I asked
her. Vice president Harris says that the
border is closed. She says it's open. As
we see these migrants coming across now,
we're not sure how many there are. We do know
that according to Texas Governor Abbott's
office, there have been about 7900 party
teaching English and English. No, I mean,
do you know there's Venezuela. Okay.
Speaker 2: So another individual correctly
identifying the Don Davis as where are
you from? And says he's from Venezuela.
Speaker 1: Hello, everybody from us, Venezuela.
Speaker 4: And remember the government.
I'm interested in celebrating Biden. We all know.
Speaker 2: So Griff asks, Is everybody on the
bus from Venezuela? And the guy says,
Yeah, mostly. You know, it's a really
difficult situation in Venezuela right now.
Speaker 4: We are scrambling to handle migration
and I mean all of the almost too many go for
don't know where to find them all. It was like
the dog removed.
Speaker 2:
So what this gentleman is explaining and
Griff Jenkins has absolutely no idea what's
being said. And it actually this would be the most
interesting thing to translate is. Yes, you know,
it's been a really difficult trip. We've been
traveling for days. They kind of screwed us in
Mexico. And we just we want to be here. We want
to do things. We want to work. I believe he said
this would actually be relevant to translate, but
of course, they're not actually set up for that.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you. Yeah. When
is our date, though? I'm not gonna be able to
translate all that. And I wouldn't even try
because it wouldn't look good on live TV.
Speaker 2: But yeah, he has
no idea what the guy said.
Speaker 1: As you can see, they're coming across
here, all of these migrants. It appears to be at
least 20 or so at this point. We have two
busses. So what was saying was we know from
Governor Abbott's office there have been about
7900 migrants on over 190 busses coming to DC.
More than 2200 are more than 40 busses to
New York and of course about five busses
to Chicago with a little over 300 migrants.
Speaker 2: Let's see if we can get one more
interview in Griff, because they're just so good.
Speaker 1: At, you know, the hours when.
Speaker 2: They don't.
Speaker 1: Chris and I did
on Years Now and Then. Dan And.
Speaker 2: So he says, I don't
understand English, which is really funny
because Griff appears to be trying this.
Speaker 3: Spanish and.
Speaker 2: This guy's like,
I don't sorry, I don't speak English.
Speaker 1: I'm an English. No,
no, no. Okay. Hello? Come on.
Speaker 2: Does the N now? He's talking to a kid.
Now he starts talking to a kid, at which
point I'm going to cut the interview.
It seems like a parody. It is important to
mention if all these folks are really coming over,
it kind of seems to prove Trump didn't
really build the wall. Right. I mean,
he claims he built it. And yet, of course, the
wall could be defeated with $100 in supplies from
a Home Depot as we learn. So no great deterrent
if it were built. But it wasn't. But Trump claims
it was. And yet these folks are still here. So
just another one of these pathetic displays get
an actual Spanish speaking reporter who can
translate, you know? The thing about it is.
If you're going to try to communicate in Spanish.
And you're going to struggle. That's okay. As long
as then you have the ability to understand and
explain what these folks are saying. Because
the guy there who told the story of how they
came to be in the U.S., traveling for days,
Mexican immigrant, all of these different things.
If you don't speak Spanish, you have no clue what
the guy said. And Griff Jenkins just laughs it
off by saying, I'm not going to try to translate
all that. These people are pathetic and it's
disgusting. Let me know what you think. Find
me on Twitter at David Pakman. We're going
to take a quick break and be right back.
The David Pakman Show is nothing but
a community supported program. You
can sign up at join Pacman dot com and get instant
access to the award winning bonus show. It's
all awards we give, I'm glad to
admit that. But a number of milestone
awards now racking up for that bonus
show. Sign up a joint Packman icon,